well I want to just give a shout-out to
Syracuse I was there this weekend oh
yeah Crowne Plaza now let me tell you I
was on plane the Crowne Plaza bun meal
this is what do you know you're in a
town god bless syracuse and i god bless
people we had fun but orange man but the
people there this one you know you're in
a town that that's that's you know
that's that's not not not San Francisco
and what do you mean run people come at
you and they go after you take place
they go thank you for coming nobody
comes here thank you
they go sorry but I'm on the plane and
this woman is sitting next to me and I
go you're going home she goes I am she
goes good sir cuz I go so where can I go
and Syracuse I give me some good spots
and she goes it is just there I go why
she go to Buffalo
Buffalo's amazing yeah Syracuse all one
up your Syracuse Friday Saturday yeah
but I had fun I went fell of course I
was there Wednesday night snowstorm ah
what's nice I was in the SMAP me bro
Wednesday night eating by myself a
cheesecake at 1:00 in the morning what
when were you there Oh January February
that it was nasty rough that I forget
but it was riza you can't go to and then
I took a train from Syracuse public
transportation took a train from
Syracuse to Buffalo that's not
depressing at all
how's that how's that how's that [ __ ]
train ride they rode done
yeah that's being a road dog it's rough
that's being a road dog train you're
going in the minute in the wintertime
where it's freezing freezing I was in
Boston waiting for the rental car truck
on in January not not dressed properly
and I was so cold it took so long that I
got him and I was 2:00 in the morning
and I went what the [ __ ]
so I said to him what I was attacking
him now yeah I was in smokin sir you're
in Spokane now let me tell you so much
more there's a place called quarter Lane
that's a half an hour outside I text you
when I was there yeah stop now it's
where Kanye has a place I didn't know
that yup Demi Moore how she Kuchar stop
it
while stars go up there there's a reason
yeah it doesn't that mean Heartland
Coeur d'Alene I looked it up
Coeur d'Alene either way amazing it is
looked up some property up their town
they really prefer a vacation home we'd
have fun how much that cost
nowhere near here I mean there's
obviously there's some
Chris but it's wanna look up just a
quarter lane properly I want to see that
I want to see nobody it's a I don't
think that's how you spell we just hired
a course Lisa CRI who are s d e where's
the s bro its quarter Lane he said us oh
I must go s is Courtney a silent its CEO
its core it's French okay cool delenn I
think it's what was that Spokane Idaho
right feel like it's Todd and I spoke in
Washington hey man what's going on right
now I have too many things in my brain
right now so kind of course all right
yeah there it is
hey Kyle buddy socio good man you are d
al e and E go just a little like
breweries everywhere good food yeah
you'd love it man French fur traders
part of an opening heart of heart of
Hawaii and all in mmm either way check
it out
okay check it out now autumn of that
that was fun man I wanted then listen to
this but I know where you going but
listen to this so I'm in I'm in Spokane
in the order Eber swing for a massage
bro nothing shady no regular massage not
from deep Asia patty crank in my neck
and I'm a [ __ ] right the thing is right
what you say what was the last part in
Mike Mike in my foot right in that foot
cook am I not yeah yeah yeah cooking
cooking you knocking my look and so I go
get a legit massage nothing shady there
right and I hop in the uber mm-hm
she was wearing a negligee and keep on
there was a and I have no problem with
this but there was a transsexual woman
who was the size of bigger than me
I'll be the me like on trial our ski no
wait Baker
okay figure that eager Samia knowledge
about the same size yeah I do of Ossus
style but white Wow big girl oh girl
look early here yeah full makeup dress
but other than that right other than
that beyond the scuffle I got my hands
full
okay heads [ __ ] we in that Ober and she
decides she gonna take me where I'm
going they didn't give me an easy fight
that's a tub eunuch scuffling the tough
big girl will you me scuffling
yeah and so
you know Ted like you listen to music
you're gonna sing and all that stuff
might that was the character and then so
sir that's some questions and I said how
are you me driving uber and start
talking are your business good she's
like no not really super nice person and
I'm like she's like no not really and
she was I can't get it I felt so bad for
her she goes I can't get a job I know
why she goes and she's turning out just
come on
I go [ __ ] because you're because you
transition she was yeah she was I
applied for jobs apply everywhere and
they won't they won't [ __ ] hire me
and she goes in Spokane I know I felt so
bad for and then we just start talking
and then I go but you're good with Ober
like uber they don't discriminate and
she was like I have some issues with
that too because I changed my profile my
name from whatever male name was her
female shoes and now they discriminate
and she was and then when I get in my
car you know by picked people up I don't
look like your normal driver so people
make fun of me I was I felt so bad I'm
like what the [ __ ] I said you need to
come to LA or somewhere where maybe it's
a little more accepted and he should be
good I don't know it's never accepted
that's tough especially if you're a
giant might I'm just saying that's
that's why I feel bad for cuz it's like
imagine if you're if you do feel that
way you have the wiring of a woman but
you're trapped in a man's body but not
only your body I tried if you were
trapped in like like you're trapped in
some Owens body they could move like
persons like it's like dude no I can't
win and then you seen Magic Johnson's
son oh yeah he's 610 yes yeah I know
like it's tough getting him out first
it's a tough gig but um I go or how
about what about your parents and she
says my dad's cool with it
my mom doesn't talk to me anymore oh
come on really yeah and then she said
yeah I know now there it is and then she
said beautiful dress and then she said
that she has four sisters ready for this
mm-hmm but originally they were born
with one brother I'm sorry she was born
with three brothers one sister oh so
that means she was born with three
brothers one sister but now he has one
brother the rest sisters so there's a
real genetic thing going on everybody
felt different yeah
I said I said growing up did you and
your sisters like no like even though
you were born as boys when your kids you
knew you're a girl she was yes we always
played with dolls we always dressed in
women's clothing choose it she goes I
don't know what the odds are if that
happening she wasn't my sister grew up
so close cuz we actually went through
this transition together I found it
fascinating sort of why and then I you
know obviously shoe stuff I might saw my
comic tipped the [ __ ] out or make her
damn a tip that [ __ ] over but uber only
lets you tip a certain percentage of it
so is like I don't know I was like a
sixteen dollar drive and they don't let
me tip 33 I don't know if I ever told
you this story but and they say you just
reminded me of getting in a car and
having a surprise but my buddy who my
Taekwondo school in Washington DC they
went to Russia to do it because there
was a guy there who was Russian who
brought them to Russia to do a tour of
Russia this is in the 90's oldschool
when when it was the Wild West
there was no longer communist and all
everybody was running all the you know
all the gangsters so we they they went
all over Russia and did these
demonstrations and did these sparring
demonstrations and back then in the 90s
they were really these guys my school
was hitting and they look good and so
they would move up these [ __ ] guys and
and they met Klitschko back then way
back in the day it was pretty cool they
had an experience so they decide this
guy decides we can make a lot of money
here we'll do it joint venture and open
a school in Moscow okay so my buddy goes
and they're there these are he looks and
my buddies pretty tough he ended up
being a CIA guy paramilitary guy I
worked all Special Forces real tough guy
but he said to me he goes dude I was
there and the dudes that were there
these Russian gangsters [ __ ] guys will
you know I mean the just a whole
different the huge guys and he goes dude
I walked in and it was like a den of
thieves and they said then they took me
to scout locations and he gets in the
back of the car and it was so obvious
because my friend ain't an angel my
friend goes this is so obvious a gang of
bad guys mafia guys that girls
that everything you wanted they're
eating caviar and [ __ ]
and he's in the backseat and they're
driving and he kind of sees something on
the floor he's fumbling around he picks
it up what the [ __ ] is this and it was a
molar it was a two zones - somebody's
tooth had been pulled out in that [ __ ]
in the back article I had blood on them
always just but it had the roots that
have been hold out on the back molar and
he went God
oh I'm in with a dennah be a cool man
play it cool
whatever you guys jokingly goes he
jokingly said um I got some beautiful
women here man they go oh the guy goes
what kind of girls you like he goes I
don't know he's choking I goes dark you
know dark hair and big tits what else do
you like you know uh huh
at his hotel room that night two girls
just and he's really my buddies really
socially awkward they treat him like it
so he was like yeah he was like oh hey
no I don't know yeah you don't know pull
the trigger he's like he said she said
me and rush questions I know it is it's
disrespect I Know Who I like all the
girls I'm like that's uh like all the
girls name something yep I'm into that
yeah I mean know all that and I'm doing
business here so I suspect a good time
when I get back no I didn't man don't
give me no time I didn't and dude how
about I had type 2 of ASSA and Tyson
pedra on the show and speaking of I mean
Russians also you have that customer
they hook it with horse but Australians
do shoe ease yeah they drink from a shoe
right well it's tyst thing he does it in
the Octagon but they take a shoe yeah
you pour beer in there but then everyone
in the group spits in it come again
you spit in the shoe now I want to just
say this disgusting my custom is
disgusting and I don't care if it's
ancient its
disgust they try to one-up each other he
said they've pissed in the shoe he said
the poor beer down each other's back
then drink other ass that's not what I
do I don't do that he's not Australian
bro no but I can't get down under I know
I don't literally hi this CBA and all
the other things I can get like like
[ __ ] in my mouth well I thought you know
either
oh I was down to do the Shoei and there
they go spinning I went and it was dude
let's disrespect you gotta spit in them
all no no [ __ ] he goes ah the Tyson goes
you and then we put a beer in it ty
drinks it no and then we do it again I
drink it and as I'm doing it Tigers you
feel that loogie down your throat that
way I feel like throwing up now to
discuss I'm not doing that [ __ ] here
here's have some of my influenza huh
it's fun though good guys you to love
them yeah I'm sure I'd love my big boys
I don't want to drink their spit I love
Samoans and Malory's I would have felt
their muscles I would ask them how much
they bench but I'm not into their spit
no you know what I mean not much your
other stuff from your dong and your spit
away from me
there's photo but yet it's friend I
won't even need a banana that somebody
bit into coz I wanted you yeah I see
double dipping in the salsa
now I'll lick an ice cream cone from a
good-looking girl cuz I'll make out with
her but I'm not doing the other stuff
now no yeah I mean either if I see
double dip in if you look at my lollipop
just [ __ ] keep it her take it by now
idea I have had girls I have had been
intimate with a woman at times a couple
times in my life and the girl has looked
at me and said spit in my mouth oh
really
yep that grosses me out I've had that do
you think that twice I went oh I was
like okay let's see I can't do that but
I don't do it I go to it was like the
girl asked me to hit her and I was like
well she just hit me and I go okay and I
can I walk wordly slapped her mouth and
she was not enough face and we were
doing it missionary and then I go where
anyone just hit me somewhere else and I
and I resented a charley horse
I hit her on there I don't like that I'm
not in I'm not in the hitting you know
that's not throw me get me off no you're
that does ruins my boner yeah I'm not
into what do you mean hit yeah like you
know hey okay let me give you a short
shot to the [ __ ] now I don't like when
girls bite don't like that either or
scratch I don't like scratching like
they need that I'm not into the
passionate no no I don't don't don't
don't don't give me marks don't bite my
lips
that's the worst [ __ ] might in a letter
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you seen no farting or
biting clean a romance novel no hell no
no no
oh that's risky we're how you feeling
about Chicago buddy I'm ecstatic your
psoriasis flared up my psoriasis is
under control let me see it's under
control
let me see though a little better a
little better a little better brother
right in time iPad special yeah you
excited about the special I'm very
excited about the special you're I
really am it's the best thing I've ever
done we're shooting Thursdays no no
we're doing a practice from Thursday so
now we're doing a show Thursday that's I
said yep Thursday - I'm ready yep and
then the [ __ ] - crashes Friday were
shooting hold on practice run losing me
feeling the crowd right we're sold out
oh we will do practice run no we're
doing a [ __ ] show it's right there
just not filming correct okay and
steel-blue why me and those TV blue eyes
is common after all
Stevie's emceeing us he's gonna insane
yeah get on and then I'm gonna coast TV
news does about four or five minutes
where the [ __ ] you want to do and then
I'll open it up I can't wait it's it's a
big deal
one on Thursday two on Friday that's
right what time are they on Friday I
don't know seven and 10 or something
like that matter does it
yeah it'd be fun though you get your
outfit okayed your golden gooses your
black only you got I got I need some
jeans the five for jeans are pretty good
but I'm gonna go and get some I'm gonna
go look at some other ones I'm gonna run
them by you and then I think that black
shirt that you sure it's good yeah I
might double up on the black shirt what
do mean dumb thing underneath it a white
one a white shirt underneath a look no
just just go do you mean underneath it I
don't you know where - sure I'll ask you
you wear two shirts
I'll show you no answer that's weird one
sure okay he's I don't know about doing
double v-neck though you know you're my
stuff man we get a crewneck be like - a
little - oh really
it looks good on you though you could do
v-neck all right I definitely do black
little can you sweat I'm black
yeah I'm doing black I'm never I'm not
making that mistake again
yeah who's all coming chintz you know
Jen's coming yeah I'm so excited I'm
glad you're coming buddy thanks man
can't wait we got chin you gonna hold
the camera and take some behind the
scenes in about your sweet-ass the eight
oh yeah yeah chin I know Jay's bummed
out
I know I'm pom JJ goes tell crying ymj
goes goes how about Brian calls me to
book your travel doesn't match anything
to me he was I what a [ __ ] came I
can't now kid so you know I've been so
um caught up in everything I just didn't
think of it I don't know why I should
have I should have you know I didn't but
I'm pumped man I'm really pumped about
it it's gonna be a lot of fun um but I
want to get into something else that has
shoes a weekend my shoes those new shoes
Don see I just northern shut up - Matt
yeah I just noticed that old school but
I think why don't you want to talk about
my collab shirt with Rachel five days of
summer no I love that no there's another
thing I wanted to talk about that I
caused a lot of [ __ ] happen as I was
gone and I just saw that there was some
stuff going on in the internet and I
guess you had a little a little tussle
with Dana White no I got it now here's
the thing here's here's my perspective
out of it a couple things one is we
haven't talked about this we haven't
talked about it at all I said well when
I say so I'll start with this when I
said that takes Brian hates when I go
after people so I seen it take someone
dude I just tweeted this it's posted
this remember he started he came after
me yeah I know because you know I hate
it I don't know I don't like getting
engaged and if you're gonna engage I
wanted to be strictly funny kind of
funny very funny thank you sir
um so I guess and I went back and
listened to you talking about gokhan
Saki yes I think was very fair and I
think was very accurate
okay Israel out of Sonia stop it was a
bad kill a bad [ __ ] and a great
fighter if he thought you were talking
about him because he didn't do his
homework so I'm sure some hate or some
fans and I'm just a clip should have
done his due diligence he didn't yeah I
get fairly funny Instagram but this was
funny he's got a sense of humor about I
thought was great but you got to do your
due diligence
Dana jumps on we all know the story Dana
jumps on but he was so aggressive and so
me he's just waiting for something he
was so mean
now now now you did you did and
I know he probably hears everything you
did compare Dana and Edie and Hearns
know I never know so I know so keep
going on I'll clear this up but you did
compare Dana no no all promoters your
yes if you do the DA water interview I
went all promoters are the same I'll
throw all of them you I don't trust
promoters
I don't just guys who drive fans I don't
just I'm Santa Claus
you don't call mall Santas guys who
drive for hands and Dana White that's
easy banks and promoters right promote
blitz no I didn't call out Dana it's
promoters in Generac but I'm just saying
but for someone to take offense to them
I know it don't act so innocent I did
that but that was towards any heard that
was a beep I didn't take it I'll tell
you what he took offense no I want to
hear but in it you did mentioned and I
remember clocking that in my head I
remember going I clocked it and I went I
went I I know Dana's very sensitive very
sensitive and I know people feed it to
him so I went mmm interesting no no this
is my thing but then he will say we met
you he came at you hard and I had to say
I thought that your response was funny
the bitter post I thought it was funny
nicer I thought it was fair and I
thought lying I thought you had a right
to come after him because he he came
after you twice pretty nationally and it
was me you know what the first one I let
slide yeah the first one I gave it like
a a mediocre each I would have said to
you I was like I'm gonna dress it just
you know I gonna Punk me me dork
response and then people were texting me
oh I I was being rubber takes back forth
I went I went Joe if he comes at me
again I'm gonna release the hounds this
I'm Tony I'm gonna Reese the [ __ ]
hell you actually said that - I tighten
on the other Luke is Luke Thomas Luke
Thomas - a good friend of mine one of
the top mmm a journalist in the world
ahead of MMA fighting now got a
promotion shouted Luke Thomas meet him
were going back and forth tonight and I
said dude if he keeps going I'm cool
I'll leave it this I don't I don't need
to win a Twitter beef I like it me buck
about that all right if he keeps going
I'm not his friend I'm gonna release the
hounds yeah and then he kept going yeah
well I was on a plane I thought let me
type this out that took me three minutes
yeah none of it none of it's a lie
there's no misinformation there there
that is what it is that's the game you
want to play now I saw you phone a
little bit how many how many when you
landed cuz you lost Wi-Fi after you
Senate [ __ ] Wi-Fi them hey you lost
the Wi-Fi tweet it and then you know
when you do let's go yeah well that's
gonna go over mmm and then now I'm like
well you're in a fight and I went sir
sir the style with the flight tailor so
uh the Wi-Fi havin trouble yes it just
went to hell cool and I went just now
yes yes I can restart it nobody'll read
it by the time your land those you know
what oh no problem
how much time left us been an hour 21
right on right on get it yeah you know
the soda water so just sit there like
and you were waiting now when you landed
how many now and don't exaggerate how
many texts would you say you got from
prominent people celebrities people in
MMA people not an mi MMA how many texts
would you say you got in generous it
just be be it don't exaggerate it is a
conservative to sort of just be
concerned X I've ever done because you
know a lot of text there's a tendency to
exaggerate I know cuz when you could you
see them all like damn that's a lot it's
a lot of text that's a long ago that was
15 times 15 that's a lot 18 because man
we're like well I'll and I get 50 like
dang let's go along well I do so don't
take big get out right yeah and in that
15 there might be one celebrity or one
guy who was a household name I know bro
so take it easy when I ask all right
yeah cuz we all tend to exact we do and
you are not a couple I yeah or a screen
shot sent to you there's that well there
is that there is that north of a hundred
I counted 110 I cannot honor his head
text from and I'd see out of 110 I
probably know of or know because they're
famous
55 at least yeah it's weird
people love gossip and they love a fight
and then they love when someone sticks
up to the bully
well yeah cuz I think a lot of people
can't really answer back Dan it tends to
be data tends to because when he gets
emotional I feel like he comes out to
his fighters sometimes you say anything
mean flash
but this law hurts their fees all
started from that B I know this started
with him [ __ ] on Francis in Ghana
and I went that's not the way to go
about things you guys have a long
history you ever know when you had
sponsors and I remember seeing the
checks I saw I saw the responses were I
saw I saw actually you get a $42,000
check from somebody way before you even
had a podcast oh yeah but he said that
all your sponsors were nil yeah I know
but that doesn't which is in your
meeting you guys remember he went up he
went yeah that's a long time ago and I
gave the contracts and my tax returns to
rogue and to give to him just to be like
dude I'm telling you barking up the
wrong tree
I'm not the guy to come after no but
also but so so so in that sense you're
also not the guy who's gonna get bullied
well I won't stand for bullying you know
and so you can get away with this with
all these guys I'm not even in the game
right I'm on the game so for him to be
so emotional and this law I was talking
about below the belt like if you think
I'm just gonna you know [ __ ] on Dana and
stuff like that now I just don't have
any hate in my heart for the guy it's
it's whatever yeah but what I won't
stand for is you being a bully because
you can't affect my career yeah UK
there's nothing can do man and and he
thinks by [ __ ] on me that's his own
insecurities he's not waking up happy
he's not waking up fulfilled you're
[ __ ] on me cuz I beat the game man
and I did despite you my show below the
belt I booked some huge names you guys
have heard of and he stops them from
coming on the show yeah there's things
I've had lined up and he stops that I'm
a different Lane now where you still
can't affect my career yeah so I'm able
to talk unfiltered no repercussions and
speak the truth you just be that sucks
for a guy like him who wants to control
the narrative the only have insecurities
and like said bro
what are you mad about you've won your
worth you're sold to company for four
billion dollars you're the CEO of a four
billion dollar company what are you
doing on social media in Instagram hey
what are you doing being a troll so it
just shows his level of immaturity and
just where he's at right now yeah I
think he's a very my experience I don't
know Dana well but I've been with him
when he was really mad at how a fight
came about ringside cage side and he was
so upset but it was more that he wanted
to put on a good show
so he takes it so personally so I think
what he is is a guy who gets very
emotional and impulsive and then I think
he's probably one of those guys like a
lot of people and by the way I do it too
sometimes where he'll lash out down at
otech and then I bet you after that
knowing that guy when he calms down he
goes out [ __ ] I shouldn't have done that
because he knows the lat he's gonna cut
get the fury back oh [ __ ] I should have
done that a problem before cuz you're
not in that Lane and oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] why
would I do that to that guy yeah because
the thing is there's guys in the youth
so he shits on everyone right and this
has been the history of Dana and that's
what he does and we just accept but
doesn't he also then renege on that and
also very rare people there no very rare
we mean help people in other words they
do jobs for me isn't he both sides of
the spectrum like sometimes he's awesome
and then he'll go the other way like
only awesome if you're awesome for him
making money okay if you're outside that
you're not awesome to him
and so my hope this all started from
with when Francis lost a fight and he
shits on France so it that's not the way
we should do things anymore that's not
the way you run a business with your
product you you don't want to you don't
want to create a bully mentality around
this Francis dad and I went this is I
went how crazy would it be if Francis
lost he's lost too he doesn't know his
ideas confidence is in the Torah how
great he would be if you the captain the
ship when I want hey man you're all
right you're gonna be fine here's what
we should do this is what I suggest
we've had guys like you before go
through this here's how to get back on
track not [ __ ] on the guy when he's down
because he's talented it just needs he's
making you money you [ __ ] yeah I don't
[ __ ] on them right he's a good guy yeah
yes maybe his ego got out of control a
lot of Fighters he goes do maybe dropped
some knowledge because you have more
experience than anyone in the building
and educate the guy a guy won't you do
that alright cuz you motivating by fear
why do you think all those texts came
through you think because people love
Twitter beef no because it's the truth
you're a dick right and and the thing is
your angers not towards me it's not what
I'm doing his show keeps going sure your
anger is with your insecurities of
yourself you dude you've made it man
we've both made it it's all good baby
what we doing well I do think just from
a business point of view to take
somebody who could be a huge earner and
has a lot of talent like France's and
Ghana has only been fighting for five
years right more or less not long
you know you got it you got to bring
them up slowly but it's it is like a
meat grinder when you do that somebody
he's already dealing with his own he's
already dealing with it with his own
diamond do fighting as a flower yeah
instead you gotta walk on eggshells I'm
worried about your job so you're
creating this this negative environment
and the numbers show that I think Dana's
taken and this isn't any ill will
towards Dana there's no that but the the
UFC's where it's at
we're not growing we're we're losing
numbers that's oversaturated he's done
what he can do with it now it's time to
get a real business mind person there
that doesn't hold these grudges and
animosity and [ __ ] on the talent and
take it to the next level Dana you did
great man you're a hall-of-famer
well the best promoters in the game you
did your thing but now it's time to see
what happens when you get a real a real
person who knows what the [ __ ] there's
nobody who like somebody the kind of
guys that run the NBA the NFL a real
busy MLB and there's no like just is so
professional yeah they're like they'll
have time to jump on Instagram and [ __ ]
on her product can you imagine
do you imagine if what a silver the head
of MBA went on LeBron James Twitter like
dude can't believe you bombed another
finals they'd be like what the [ __ ] are
we doing he would lose his job yeah
that's right it's insane that's right
and I also think that for me I I just
could never recover I was pumped from
her I've never been in the Octagon so I
wouldn't know I'd like to quickly see
that's why you treat guys like that
though cuz he's never been there cuz I
guarantee you anyone who's been there
we're not treat to now because I'll but
also if you haven't been there it's you
got to know that and say you have to be
a little bit respectful of the fact that
they're just you know what they're going
you would hate it they would know a guy
on a two fights kid how he's feeling to
make it into the heavier das Goodell
heard as a pro you ever heard him or
Bernard Hopkins just completely [ __ ] on
someone like that and make fun of the
career anything like that no because
they bake there weren't any boxers to
that including the commentators no no
I'm saying as a promoter Bernard Hopkins
in industrial her promoters do they have
been that sure they made that walk so
they might throw shade that guy's sure
but they're not gonna come up to Mike
they want a [ __ ] scrub he should what
yeah the only date like I can see if
somebody has a lot of talent and they
don't train they come up there and they
[ __ ] the bed then you've got like a
reason to go he's just lazy it could be
great but he's lazy and he won't be then
then there are criticism it's different
sure it's different but but I yeah but
but did you get it I have to ask this um
but I I don't I'm not trying to stir the
pot but I do feel like since if you
listen to cuz I went back and listened
cuz you know I'm protective so and you
were talking specifically about gokhan
Saki love yo and we heard that you were
very clear about that I think most
mostly I made a mistake and not
listening you heard somebody tell him no
did he reach out and apologize no we
don't know each other we don't know each
other
for like a cool guy let's know I'm sure
he's great yeah I didn't list them on
road road so he's a great guy I don't
know him obviously tons of skill he you
know I sit I shot him a DM on Instagram
my brother I'm telling you you get this
confused this isn't about you keep doing
your thing I'm sure to be champ someday
good luck with everything
yeah I I don't know the good 37 here at
55 no 785 he's 85 that's right the thing
about with him is uh you know I bit when
I was fighting yeah I didn't look in a
lot of things if people would pick
against me it fueled a fire so I get
that what he's doing he's just wrong on
this point he doesn't owe me an apology
on you like if anything - I mean I'm
sure he's gotten the most of his
productivity he's never got in his life
on you know now that's not just throwing
shade but by me and Dana common and
getting this beef on his Instagram I'm
sure it's helped his fall I love
watching your sing why I'd since that I
since that I looked them right I love
watching that guy fine she's almost rice
to the nominal Wow yeah he's off of this
one but it helped his Instagram game so
good for me on young woman for him young
lion yeah well there it is Yemen there
it is what do you do well what you gonna
do is keep moving forward let's no
matter what are they gonna do again I'm
too busy I will see how let's see how he
deals with this is my new this is my new
formula for success at 51 would you want
to be successful you just keep moving
you
keep doing it I know you failed I failed
I suck just keep going keep going
I didn't fail so I hear you but the
thing is is that I didn't fail you come
out something different but in regards
to this I mean no now sure after I roast
him dragon offal from Comedy Central's
beyond roast battle yeah I did it so
there's some positives out and I get do
I'm not sure but still yes you did I
mean it was a great week that's what
happens with dad you gots others show
starved the movie I mean you also shows
in Spokane which were packed God they
were very excited about the whole feud
now were they chanting Eskimo at the end
of the show yeah I heard some rumors
now is there a rumor that there's an
Eskimo bro shirt coming out yes okay
don't make me get a tattoo of it sorry
Eskimo brothers yes Brian you and I are
just kids because we just cuz we wife
swap doesn't mean rumors rumors rumors
I'm excited for Chicago man yeah I'm
excited I'm pumped and I'm excited to
not to promote any dates right now
taking a break you can shoot your
special then what's the plan I'm gonna
shoot my special I'm gonna go to Beijing
China I'm gonna shoot my movie I'm gonna
take three days to do that I'm gonna
come right [ __ ] back well it's me
great for your stress it's gonna be
great for my psoriasis I'm gonna come
right back and I'm gonna be here in this
town for 13 episodes of my new TVs which
I'm shooting the Goldbergs I'm shooting
two TV shows in a row at the same time
you do simultaneous oh you both eight
minutes away from our studio thank God
doesn't matter there's nothing to do
with it that doesn't matter at least I'm
not driving
yes I'm not and I'll tell you something
else now how many episodes of fires the
killer you miss you think you let's say
all I'm not gonna miss any my quote that
[ __ ] now I've already worked it out to
action schedule no I'm not missing I bet
you okay which is all good no I can't
that'd be a long schedule though so you
take the rest of your off you think six
months unless I want to rerun I don't
want to fire back up and write and start
we don't want to travel this you have a
new hour I don't do the same L know I
want to start but the other thing is
yeah but you also with the special we
gotta figure
where it's given land and when out drops
to yeah that's another issue I have to
have I asked I have to come up with a
name but you'll watch it yeah we'll
figure it out yeah haven't seen it so
yeah we're at the Comedy Store I'm gonna
put you on the cover with those shoes
and no clothes on to it and call it
American boner oh no just do these shoes
me butt naked with a Siberian Husky and
that says Eskimo bro
Eskimo that's good by the way my name my
name and every show now is the psoriasis
kid
yeah guy made me a t-shirt a big answer
because maybe a big girl I meant to
bring it goddamn it when she was really
cool with any head little like balls
little yarn balls on the bottom is
hilarious that's interesting and and he
spelled my name bright Bray on column
and it's just [ __ ] hilarious but yeah
I'm the big arrow or on the psoriasis
kid and in Oklahoma needs to be gay
eagle and I'm the big gay so I got a lot
of stuff going on for me
good good nicknames everybody King James
and then the big game are you excited to
take your break from stand up your make
it on the road for I and what are you 12
years 12 years 13 years I'm done for a
little bit it'd be nice
neither roads of iron backup roads are
local gigs with you yeah you know why
not
it's always fun they hang out Tommy
Store on Tuesday together yes we are you
want to set Wednesday Wednesday I'm
doing one hour at the Venice town hall
all the time
the Venice underground so if you're
around what does the Venice finals on
the ground I'm doing it at I start at
10:00 but I think Wednesday I have a gig
as well I think I'm doing the Comedy
Store where are you doing are you doing
what meet me and so you'll have our show
with you and friends the sting in the
King Oh Tommy stores sold out you want
to do a separate out do a set there too
yeah be good and then maybe I'll come
with you to wherever you're doing right
I'm doing a one-hour and then Tuesday we
have a Tuesday we have do please yes
yeah yeah that'll be good we agree yeah
it's a lot why are you laughing well uh
what there's nothing
what's it funny it sounds like [ __ ] in
it do you know I mean who for I didn't
know but no I hit my nose so she long or
maybe I don't the barbecue outside no we
have beer here remember all the barriers
Robin no but I don't know for sure it
was you know I hear I was like it hit me
so hard I was on a plane no conversation
I was on a plane the guy starting
letting go and I was like dude you
always have to say something with
someone's doing that bother I look
around I go come on man did general look
down tonight food doing [ __ ] my pants
sorry I took a poo I smell it now is it
the worst smell of all time it was bad I
just got here is there a water buffalo
loosen the bit don't smell anything Oh
people are working on the roofs right
now and are they shooting or they worked
out better than [ __ ] up there so they
could be for hang it could be hidden us
now there's no way this is like someone
took [ __ ] and smeared on the roof really
you shall nothing old man nothing Wow
maybe I'm going crazy no I smell - oh my
dog Street on my couch I started
screaming today your dog chewed up your
couch because there was a goddamn court
there was a bomb to the cage
say no more no no I don't hey I want you
to come on down hey the key under the
mat the code still three three three
three
I want you no problem come on it
[Music]
might take your query on the spiking Oh
chin you know chin went fishing this
weekend you know you did know did you
throw all the dead bodies overboard
before you should I say that'd be too
hard this fishing mean catch and kill
and dump in the harbor decision mean is
catch boxfish mean go to the bar looking
for dudes dead did two dudes fishing for
dick no day they caught a serial
one of the guys who was dumping he's
killing people and putting them in he
would dump them in the river you know
certain on the back that's not the
profiler goes just go to the go to go
right to the side of the road you'll
find him
think of what he meetings he'll be in
his car masturbating you'll see sure
enough make out yep there he was jerking
off remember looking at the site of
where the bodies are just remembering
what is Jesus right those profilers can
do some [ __ ] you know what they're all
the same to this hostage negotiator talk
about how money is the easiest thing to
trace you know they catch gangs money
money all day it's not real the money
trail it did the ceremony made easiest
thing the trail yeah but also when when
you talk to them you can get all the
information it just get stitches how old
are they where are they from the other
word they grow up you can tell from
their accents and everything FBI notice
some [ __ ] on you man the minute you open
your mouth they know everything
hmm hardest crooks think they are are
FBI or law even the way you do something
even the way you carry out the crime how
you open the door all that it's just a
treasure trove of information they can
narrow that [ __ ] right down then they
trace down the money there this this
kidnapping gang in Ecuador I think and
they would get away with it and they
were just in the family they killed an
American
they killed in America and then we
executed an American look and the FBI
was like they go
the FBI was like oh oh this is our
problem now yeah now this is our problem
so what they do so they they gave the
ransom money for the next kidnapping and
they just followed the money and they
rounded up all 50 of them they caught
the 50 [ __ ] people go ahead and [ __ ]
with the FBI what they do what he was
talking about a lot of jurisdiction in
it well there's an old saying he
wouldn't say there's an old saying I
will bring you to justice or we'll bring
justice to you because the American they
the armed the long room of American
justice the arm of American justice is
very long and it's very patient you hear
these [ __ ] dudes talking you're like
don't ever want to be on the wrong side
and he goes here's when you rob a bank
there's a hostage situation when you do
anything like that you're not getting
away never you not get no one ever has
everything ever got away but he said
you'll get guys who are really
controlling really cold I mean real
sociopaths and he even had one dude one
dude who is this you're talking to
there's a podcast with sam harris he was
this gotcha
he said one dude was a real associate
about terrorists real killer and the FBI
hostage guy was trained in psychology
and he was able to get the hostages out
for money okay and the terrorist the
head of the terrorist called the hostage
guy back and goes hey I just want you to
know I appreciate the way you treated me
with respect and you seem like a good
guy
those guys the mob - you should listen
to him this is less Sam Harris's last
pause gasps yes some Christian yeah the
first one is I checked everywhere it's
legit and it's freaky so Brock Lesnar
did you guys ever hear about his teeth
yeah I know about us - you know what do
you know 100 your headline is with bad
teeth how he grinds them set the film in
I've never seen how they looked and then
there's a picture here yeah they look
like a little tree stumps huh they look
like they're hollow Oh holes they're not
hollow hoes they fill him because he
grinds so much so they can't get worn
down anymore Wow
authority so that's why I thought no one
really knew the answer
that's a tough what it is that's a tough
tooth yeah you mean teeth all of them on
the bottom yeah he grabs his teeth so
it's a big man with some tiny teeth
chapped lips dude and there's a thing
called I think it's trip trip - phobia
someone thought where people have a fear
of like a lot of holes next to each
other which I do have that fear or not
fear but it grosses me out what does a
bunch of holes yeah like there's a
there's a frog somewhere that has like
slits in its back a bunch of slits and
then it's babies come out of the slits
yeah like that stuff I can't look at
I'm kids tariffs right what else give me
another example like polka dots like on
this wall no no none but it's weird so
it's like if you're watching a gangbang
is to make holes for you here trip both
phobia see this stuff that doesn't freak
you out
oh sure [ __ ] does it no but that
sunflower see but it probably Dell oh my
gosh really even like some like this
with this I don't even click on it but
there's a hand and that's got a lot of
holes in it
well that hand with holes and it freaks
you out cuz it's the human hand that's
also that's also you're so that's also
from an evolutionary biology standpoint
they click on that gender will you have
trip we're wary of strangers and
strangers who look like that because
we're afraid of disease we've evolved to
be that's part of where stranger danger
and how human beings don't like the
other tribe it's how they kept from
getting all let me see this you tell us
some different be that's gonna make
sense now if you see that you're like
get it away from can you watch 60
seconds of tiny noise let me see change
can you Jim are you I'm gonna see what
try phobia is the fear of small
clustered holes no problem you might
have it nope celebrate that she can test
his dick in her hand
I'm sinking like I don't understand why
do they make me feel so queasy your
shirt makes me queasy it's really weird
though because whenever I see something
I can't stop looking at it that is weird
so want to throw up do you have a
dispatch in it bothers me let me see
what happens when they want it that's
not bad those are particles yeah not bad
to me
that's not bad to me at all that's not
bad
that is getting worse coffee dot that's
coffee that's oil yeah that's not good
that frog that's not that bad dude you
don't have it's like a whole trip bro
you don't have sunken in that that
bothers me those are sports those are
sunflowers that are dried out just
saying though for whatever reason the
way honeycomb looks delicious
that's a spider what about slider eyes
now it's gross I'm like I feel like my
body is on fire do it
oh girl you hose down that looks freaky
let's all who just drawn their hand like
that that still looks freaky I don't I
don't get it
let me see if I can find that frog are
there any other extreme what's another
weird phobia that one's pretty rude
phobias have hair
some people have phobia I can't watch
like scat babes I'll throw up enough of
course you are okay yeah yeah this
that's not phobia let's just be in queue
you don't eat poo perfectly so there's a
frog with the holes in its back and then
watch so like a 14 or was its grosses
you out chin on his bed I don't know I
can't describe what it is exactly
chin hey bro you're reaching here you
don't have it don't try taking the rain
man don't try taking the credit I dunno
you mean like little eggs and things
like that okay you don't have it either
bro don't try jumping on this love frogs
creeping out of its back and feet that's
cool Oh terrible chin up no nice try you
don't have it bro I hope I don't have
this fish a type and type in weirdest
phobias there's some people are like
scared of oh I don't know
dicks do you know that no yeah there's
some people are like freaked out by
critics I I'm serious man just big old
heavy dates with a with a ridge yes
scares them and a vein
yeah yeah I was not going in me I don't
like what why would you type draw line
on that with 25 weirdest focus a blue -
phobia where you're too scared to take a
bath yeah but that's what that's what
rabies does to you really yeah what's
this one
ergo phobia what's this it is fear such
as feeling at assigned tasks social
anxiety and public speaking oh yeah
whatever that's all pharmaceuticals
nomophobia no mobiles okay that's lame
that's you don't have your phone with
you oh there's people that like freaked
out don't have the phones with them I
got a little legitimately from out sent
ya like could feel like you've lost a
goddamn arm or something fear of
commitment
well yeah you talk about every guy keep
going are these real yes obeah also
knows who's in control nightmares have
been known to cause it as well yeah bees
are lame though these aren't real bro
kilo phobia Neil yeah these aren't real
I mean they might be but I don't care
everybody's afraid of something you have
crazy people
no but there's phobias where people like
they can't I can't they can't yeah
arachnophobia obsessive-compulsive
disorder has certain phobias in it yeah
but there's people are like terrified of
states where they seem they've seized
yes arachnophobia yeah that spiders yes
yeah what is the like you're scared of
like you hate straight lines Keith yes
yeah I like it to be squiggly I'm
terrified of a string you know it
straight you want to jump I'm afraid of
being straight I mean do you like things
you don't you don't like things in my
life things to take a curve oh here we
go a fear of noise fear of heights fear
of sharp pointed objects that's
got fear of cats I just don't like them
Andrew phobia well hmm you definitely
have that be what's hand trigger of
adult man what's the opposite of that
dick oh i of course--i no phobia fear of
cancer definitely have that I think all
of us fear of colours we admit but
there's some people are straight-up
scared Chopra phobia fear of feces and
defecate I'm pretty scared yeah that's
you know what but I don't stance up like
my son [ __ ] in the tub Jose goddamn it
I'll gag ya get it away from me
yeah decide Oh phobia fear Magnus isn't
shut up alright goodnight let's move on
Owen bored aversion to female genitals
Hiro - oh yeah you're at OPA phobia do
you think you have that chat we are your
fanatic these are all real huh
yeah fear being laughed at jello Topa
phobia know about that you're funny
thanks bro silly goose er what else you
got chin all right
fear of nudity Jim no phobia hmm how can
you get off and I know for me alright
the next one this one's the headline is
pretty crazy but then the more I looked
into it I'm with this guy now so a guy
in South Beach was no arms is accused of
stabbing someone with scissors he's an
armless South Beach artist yeah but you
could use your mouth of your feet right
use his feet and I'm with South beats
are accused of stabbing with scissors
okay what's the problem how supposed to
protect him first of all just reading
that use it's like how you do it but
then you figure out this feat and then I
guess two people this is what they're
saying
drove up next to him and asked him for
directions and then they accused this
guy of going ballistic on him and
stabbing him with scissors so he's a
painter he paints with his feet mm-hmm
he might be a little crazy
no so people looking a lot in the
comment sections show up a chin you just
do me a favor show barstool post a
picture of them you tell me if he's
crazy Brian let's just jump to
conclusions here let's play game let's
jump to again let's do a game called
is he crazy I don't want to judge a book
by it's cover but I know his life is
very hard yeah but just judge this by
its cover and do me a favor think if
this man looks all there he definitely
doesn't have the looks do you and him
out the same neck yes
those are very interesting years that's
the least of his books like he's got he
looks like he's had a hard time mmm they
they're very fascinating face he looks
like he's had the hard stuff he looks
like he's had the hardest I think you're
right he does look like he's it's like
I'll stab people with his feet yeah
that's it that's tough
he does but a lot of people that know
him they were commenting saying that
he's like this harmless guy on the on
that wherever he's at doing artwork it's
so nice he's keeps to himself he's quiet
so people think that those two guys were
probably being agitated yeah they'd
probably be Dixon and also also how
could you see that come from mouth I was
gonna say can you move out of the way
the contingent ski shake his feet like
dude what are you doing right like what
get the paintbrush bro and also you know
did he grab both the knife instead it's
hard but it's good or does he pick out
and like [ __ ] Liu Kang you know
you're fine you didn't get stabbed your
baby where'd he stab on that bro he was
lying down hopefully in the dawn or
maybe that guy's like staring offing he
just stabbed him in the ass maybe but
either way I think this guy was being
all damn it says according to the police
report the dude with no arms was laying
down and these guys kicked him in the
head
that's his bench all stabbed Granada
twice and fled the scene I think they're
a shitty kid the friend who was
traveling a cop said no arms they asked
finish all four directions when he
suddenly jumped up and stabbed her on
his arm
you said god I bet they were doing
something dude yeah I want you to go
back for a second I want to say one
thing two faces I want to say something
and I don't mean I want to just say
something no don't be a dick no because
he's not looking want you to think about
this and I want you to know this that
man right there that you're looking at
is exactly five years younger than I am
don't laugh don't laugh
oh I'm just telling you the facts so
life has been hard for that gentleman
the hardest and those [ __ ] who
kicked him deserve to be stabbed I agree
if they were being [ __ ] I grew and
they kicked it out ahead
not oversell himself yeah that guy's had
it tough cat though we see woodsy is he
well how did he lose his arms do we know
I don't know he's [ __ ] I think is
probably with you born like this hey
Tina you need somebody to help you you
know put a hat on and put sunblock on no
unique and then you got these [ __ ] kids
coming up do you mess with you so he
stabs Liese just stabbed him in the arm
too how do you even go to the bathroom
with no arms you know it sucks how do
you get your pants off it's good there's
a lot of yeah that's right I mean
goddamn just basic human dignity as a
[ __ ] beast yeah you laughed at
him for the record you did all I said
was well when he brought up exactly
guilty he's exactly saying I've killed
years younger
what are you saying he looks old bro I'm
just saying now am i saying could you
guys be brothers yeah and I went a bad
night to it but there there's a chance
we could be related that's your younger
brothers had a little harsher life made
it's not the smartest decision had a
tough time of it but but I hope he has
somebody taking care of him
yeah I bet he does he's an artist and
he's selling artwork he's got to have
some people around it sounds like those
kids who made fun of him get what they
deserve my life to the goddamn arm
people suck man they rock yeah
scissors there's too much negativity out
there man well there are these stories
these kids light knocking out bombs and
lighting homeless people have fire and I
live there are [ __ ] in the world we
know this what else you got Jim all
right let's go so what's on the other
side is true always greener on the other
side you don't have psoriasis you do
you're right older you know the
Kardashians that I found out they all do
now
there's I bet you there's cleared up a
day probably and you've been struggling
for years in light therapy now what else
you alright this one it's a the most
recent post that Conor McGregor did with
him in Putin and I guess people are mad
at him because of what he's saying about
mericans are ya Russians are and
remember he's trying to fight khabib in
Russia so taking a picture with Putin is
what you do so he just took the picture
up so you know he's not
loves fighters first of all it's what he
says though yeah it has nothing to add
yeah I was invited the World Cup final
as you get to the Russian president this
man is one of the greatest leaders of
our time though I was not honoring
people it will the Grizzlies have until
my marker men on one side today
was not it for me mr. Putin thank you
and congratulations on an amazing World
Cup yeah what do you think I mean some
people are saying this is a marketing I
don't expect Conor McGregor to have a
nuanced opinion about geopolitics or
dictators I think he was just being
inhalation history I think he was being
gracious to a president of a major power
in that moment I think I think Ryan's
right but I also think it's listen he's
the best marketer of all time and you
see history he's also trying to get a
fight in Russia against khabib so
opposed to picture this is gonna get a
lot of [ __ ] Conor McGregor's adulation
of but sodomite Putin means nothing
either way I understand that the Putin
is a dictator but you know it's not it's
not for Conor McGregor to be taking a
political stance no it was a brilliant
marketing move he was a guest especially
against the most powerful man in Russia
and kabhi was there too yeah yeah and
and and Putin loves MMA right he loved
he I'm sure he'd watched like fatal
times he probably loves phaidor how do
you not love the fitter
he's a putin's a black belt in judo is
it sound sound probably yeah so Putin is
very very up probably on loves MMA and
look how do you not love Conor McGregor
well Conor McGregor's world famous
probably a rock star in Russia so oh man
did you [ __ ] all the girls what else yet
yeah all right this is uh Elon Musk
he had tweeted out that's now deleted he
tweeted out about a British diver that
was giving him you know crap about how
his techniques were not gonna work in
the Thai cave so on the the the diver
was given young musk crap yeah things
like he was saying that those things
would not work in this cave you have to
be in the cave to realize that whatever
the stuff they just what a lot of
experts say Hamas was like I'm gonna
build this
and we're gonna go in there and the
experts like doesn't really work that
way dude just let us do our thing yeah
yeah so what happened so one must
started tweeting a bunch of different
things and he called the guy a pedo a
pedophile so you know what don't bother
showing the video we'll make one of the
many sub pubs going all the way to a k5
no problem probably Moe sorry pedo guy
you really did ask for it
yikes and here's loser lon it's
unfounded - so there's no evidence of
this guy being a pedo whatever so this
is why people are getting upset with
Elon Musk well yeah I must like let the
experts do their thing bro you don't
need be on the front cover of everything
like to me a little bit with you on he's
brilliant I like what he's doing but
he's got a little bit of a Fame [ __ ]
he said bet your sign dollar it's true
he said that mm-hmm and he deleted these
tweets too so that says some well you
wound up Dana White didn't like came
after a guy and it's you you [ __ ] on a
guy trying to save kids do you win Elan
out of dicks of the week come on down
yeah that's not so cool
yeah thanks anyhow that's there well I
said billion dollars dude be cool man
yeah that's where - huh he's worth so
much and yeah I think there's a lot of
[ __ ] though cuz you went from trying to
help the world out and do all this stuff
and then now like every problem anyone's
like well dude relax you don't need
people you in there yes that's what
that's what all the experts are saying
the Navy SEALs like dude work here
that's not gonna work and he's like nope
we're going in with like no no we got
this so why are you getting so
passionate about I stay out of it yeah
you becoming like a little bit of a Fame
[ __ ] but just scary there's definitely
you go there man yes yeah which is a
bummer he was he was like America's
Sweetheart first I become the Kim
Kardashian of rocket scientist like
chill out man yeah what else you got
alright this a Jaguar this is in New
Orleans escaped from his enclosure to go
to another enclosure and kill the like
nine animals at this point
you evening Jaguar doing Jaguar [ __ ] but
it escaped its enclosure which is but
forget the food trap this goddamn cage
she's like dude how many down that's a
field day for him yeah so what all did
he kill like email or Oscar yeah they're
cool
killing EMU what else I'll pack us four
of them and then a fox a parkas our
llamas basically yeah correct
you kill them all there they're hairy
lot much smaller long this this alpaca
farm that was there it'll stay together
Maui those those animals with walks
alpacas and Eamon we kill the Fox yeah
we were in Napa Valley and Rogan and I
were hunter key and this is not pakka
farm and the guy who owned it said and
this was the pockets are really really
tall bring up an alpaca
meanwhile the [ __ ] orzo llama a
mountain lion jumped over the fence
killed the alpaca and then jumped over
the fence with the alpaca aqui they look
like Terry llamas leaves are smaller
though they're really cute apparently
they make good pets
they're cute they are cutest yeah
there's a bug there's people out here
who have them is they actually make
great pets but they are they will be by
wolves and by [ __ ] yeah toasty mountain
lion anything yeah no it has no defense
don't mess with them they're dilute
though they're really cute and I'll pack
a wool is warm warmer [ __ ] the other
first they're really cute they are cute
so but they didn't put that Jaguar down
right No thank God Jake why doing jack
[ __ ] bro it's all don't let him out he's
gonna kill Jaguars will kill people too
they don't [ __ ] around
Jags are not afraid of people they'll
take you out guy said to me works with
cats
you guys I work with lions tigers lions
we're more dangerous and tigers because
their pride animals and they they can
read your body language but he goes flat
Birds I can deal with not Jaguars
you may go Titan jag wouldn't make a
right turn one day and he wanted to go
left he just jumps game over yeah yeah
300 pound cat what else reaction alright
the next one is Sasha Baron Cohen
hilarious he has a news show on Showtime
and I guess during the show he was able
to convince
like lawmakers that maybe his idea of
arming kindergartens kindergartners with
guns as young as three years old and
training them how to shoot one guy says
one guy I don't know who's the senator
but it was right here
well they're not that they're not
they're not prone to homosexuality so
they're and their reaction times better
or something yeah Barry Cole is
brilliant worthy were they joking though
I want to know if they were joking were
they were they joking when they said it
no so notice I assume though they were
saying that he like had on the
teleprompter that they were reading off
of or something like that so it wasn't
like them saying their exact opinions
but we have to see the show to really
figure it out
he's brilliant with this weapons the
drone was soft Troy's gonna Milles
children's songs he's so brilliant man
great so funny Wow yes I don't know who
this person is Joe Walsh he's a former
congressman the alternative just trolls
people non-stop yeah you want to wait
for a while and I he's backed I'd best
way to fight anything if you disagree
with this with humor that's a classic
example he's great at it's so funny once
again let's go here so I've heard this
on Joe Rogan's podcast before that he'd
okay this for a hot yeah that Michael
Jackson was a castrato that is which
father castrated him took his balls off
when I was a little kids to get to
maintain is Khattak excited so he used
chemicals to do it hmm so they don't cut
anything you just take these chemicals I
destroyed your nuts oh my yeah I guess
it's like drugs that he had to take what
[ __ ] guy but this is his Michael
Jackson's doctor saying that oh Jesus
Christ
that's incredible yeah and they did it
because they didn't want his voice to
change right wonder he was such a mess
what a monster you aren't telling me his
dad just I'm up you mean you tell me in
that picture his dad does not look like
a horned toad
well his dad is harsher he died it like
80 or 90 or something you're [ __ ]
ready you did there's this doctor what's
his doctor say who he was chemically
castrated Michael Jackson was killing
tested as a child by his recently
deceased father by so his dad did it
yeah
because I mean Marie who was convicted
of involuntary manslaughter two years
prison falling fatal dose that what
killed Michael Jackson says one of the
worst fathers just children history the
former cardiologist added that when
Jackson was his patient the singer told
him about many sufferings he experienced
at the hands of his father as a child
keep going huh the fact that he was
chemically castrated to maintain his
high-pitched voice is beyond words Jesus
in which he accused Jo a fortune Michael
to get hormone injections at age 12 to
cures acne and prevent his voice from
changing I hope Joe Jackson finds
redemption in hell all right Wow that
[ __ ] terrible it kind of makes sense
that wouldn't it we wouldn't want to be
us all makes sense actually
it was more than just belt on it was
more than just belt chords whatever was
around he'd throw you up against the
wall at all he could he would lose his
temper oh I was so fast he couldn't cast
me half the time but when he would cast
me it was bad goes getting beaten by a
terrible person man I know what's Pierce
Jackson say his daughter well you know
all of us LaToya Jackson didn't know him
had anything good to say about Jo so
damn yeah I'm not sure if she's
referring to you yeah that's heavy Troy
bad guys you think I'll just get it if
you could have the career of Michael
Jackson whenever I was like did you know
Michael Jackson yes Mike that's not just
take these injections you're just gonna
shrink your balls right that's cord
around your nuts no till it turns brown
you wouldn't doing be Michael Jackson
hell no you know what you know I
wouldn't do it
why it'll be on [ __ ] chicks I mean so
famous can't do [ __ ] yeah you'd do
anything you can't do could still bone
them but you just won't having kids
mmm you have no testosterone you have no
sex drive hmm yeah and like a lot of
people with no testosterone you don't
want to have sex Jen
you have zero testosterone in your body
and you never go through puberty you're
not trying to [ __ ] Jake I don't know why
a lot of people say who were around
Michael Jackson tons bo know him well go
I never got a sexual vibe Everett I
thought he's asexual
I thought he was just like I always
I'm worried about I wonder about Tom
Cruise - Oh like he dates but never Tom
Cruise - [ __ ] you proper boys Mission
Impossible kidding
Tom Cruise will [ __ ] your mouth take it
easy
Mission Impossible what does that mean
meeting [ __ ] it bro but but as I thought
he lines up so he can dump in their
mouth because Shuhei dumped
don't say our crew being so aggressive
sexually right now Tom comes in stop he
doesn't seem to have a relationship and
doesn't seem to make one likes on the
deal bro
yeah the cruise yeah bro come on you
think you just mission doing all you
like you know you just put all your know
here bro you just think you're your Tom
Cruise doing all your own stunts stunts
and I get your dick sucked when you're
off set yes I'm goddamn mine I know
people have done movies with them and
they're not they haven't seen anything
like that he's been good Oh Lord free
pun [ __ ] all these girls don't worry
about that right well he's just hanging
out with them look man I mean I believe
I don't think he's gay I'm just saying
whoa Sophie she was hanging out with him
met her by the way you couldn't look
better yes she's beautiful
he was married to Penelope Cruz right
yeah there's hey Amanda Court hey Mimi
Rogers
Niraj is the hottest thing I've ever
seen in my life what oh my god I met her
on that so she was 45 and I'm 97 I met
her on the set of seventh heaven I look
at her body I've never seen it go to
Mimi Riley I mean my life she looks bus
I've never seen anything like it in my
life and she was 45 when she was younger
forget it game over there is no one with
a better body I said it clicked on her
there's no one with a better body when
she was young her body says no one
there's no one interesting and that's
the daughter hardest thing I'd ever seen
oh my god I couldn't believe it oh I
couldn't believe it she's all turned out
but Jesus Joe looks like Demi Moore a
little bit when she was younger
forget it forget it huh I'm telling you
man weird III I was astonished and it
makes just no
yeah you probably zero period she was a
there we go
she was a different look at her click
zoom on that chin all natural and all
curves the crazy should have ever seen
it's pretty hot I'm telling quagmire or
whatever she was younger
no she better hope she know she looks
pretty there for sure unreal
yeah Daryl has another one I've seen in
in personnel heaviness Daryl Hannah when
she was younger
oh my god some of these women that like
became obviously they become famous
because they love their get in there
with that bathing suit they're over
there all the way over here no here yeah
in pretty standard be you know talk
about this phobias a gang yeah I had
nothing bro either way Tom Cruise is
[ __ ] you'd never never get your wires
how it expands right he's putting it
down right
you think huge movie star on cruise
doesn't seem to have any relationships I
feel bad for him he's had more than us
bro well he's alone I want to see that
mission be responsible I heard it said
oh good really yeah I'm not a mission
wealthy guy makes great movies he's a
beast he makes great movies he's got he
doesn't all zones he's awesome yes
collateral was an incredible movie he's
made that movie die eat repeater of the
removing amazed a great movie you know
he brought you know that to stop
production cuz he jumped from bill and
building broke his ankle yeah let me see
him break his stun man I've had long
talks with stuff I mean you know when
he's hanging out the helicopter you know
it's really him and they're like dude
this one we don't advise you to do it's
a little bit dangerous and they're like
in the by mount ever some [ __ ] and he
refuses to let anyone else OS he's 50
bro older than that ball it's 55 dude I
mean hey I think you me I'm not don't
say to you at all yeah what I'm saying
is 56 he's 56 he looks better than you
bro he's the only 50 oh that I know that
looks better in you well Frank relative
Oh Frank's a dime P Frank Frank looks I
just marvel at how good ain't me to now
see on all the Stewart's because Tom
Cruise isn't yeah
I wonder if Tommy's doing Tom you know
times oh just a little punk whatever I
t's a badass man you don't get enough
respect and you know whatever mercy what
they say on set nice is kind of world
nicest but beast logo camera three over
here make sure you in this before and
yes yes yes they say they had my
experiences with him personally he's
very nice I know people that work with
them and then directors and they say
there's there is ready none better in
Hollywood you know what they say I'll
every time I've seen he gets the weird
ship for Scientology but they say
professionally now yeah that's why I
work with them like intimately and and
this is how they describe you ask what's
he like they go nice scandal oh he's the
nicest man in the world
yeah he is he's a really nice any
remembers everyone's name he's just so
far like if he gave me an hour with them
I'd call you next morning but here we
doing brother dude I'm in Scientology
now yep one hour yeah you like what are
you doing I'm like dude I can't make it
a wipe Scientology I'm dating and I'm
dating right now and I'm dating to set
me up with someone I'm taking and and
I've taken they said no doesn't see how
I work for now I'm security for come
true dunker you'd be a security guard
his personal bodyguard yeah I'd be a
terrible job mmm-hmm he's small man five
seven fifty six years old here's Josh he
is only jet 575 yeah I've been in same
parties and walk right by yeah and it's
so impressive he's a wide dude though I
wouldn't classify him as that much I
don't know
Jamie's from Syracuse in New York and
you [ __ ] on this town before we got here
you know what I don't you doing I can
explain the great late Tom Cruise you
mean I didn't mean it alright been
married three times I took I took my son
it's the first movie he's ever sat the
full length through Transylvania three
you just want to go on that today you
just want to Adam Sandler's most
successful movies really gents we need
one two and three he wrote and directed
him he wrote and directed oh yeah
produce wrote my kid my kid is the kid
is gone my kids are gone today they're
grown no you don't say that grown but
for a two-year-old you know [ __ ] yeah
extraño he did amazing he grew up
watching channel 31
from Sylvania it's pretty good it's not
as good as the other two but it's good
sure that's Hotel Transylvania yeah sure
it's not directed by Adam Sandler I
don't think it's written mice know it is
I promise
also not produce padam Sam no no the
third one's not the first - one of the
characters nope you want to bet
well friendly bet go to Transylvania 1 &
2 chin wait let me go to the idea I'm dB
please do
well it'll said yep just making sure but
stars writers stars writers not written
by director he stars in it no I'm
telling you the producer I'm looking at
right there yeah yeah so shut up
I promise first 2 written created by
Adam Sandler no it's him another guy to
him not there I didn't think he wrote it
the problem she can write that problem
what can I hear the writers are you
can't write that you know he's written a
lot of [ __ ] brother not really oh yes
yes writing people should have bet on it
Adam hasn't been a writer Adams more Ben
and more of a producer and an actor in
it oops he's got a team of people who
write different directors yeah no he
directed I promise she's a co-writer on
it Jin's also the worst Googler of all
time I came here for that well it says
here though it was suggested that
director genndy tartakovsky that Adam
Sandler had more creative control over
this yeah and then look at look at the
two on full cast and crew hotel crew
credits actors just written who does he
play it plays that vampire Count Dracula
yeah he's the main guy the third one's
not as good though no no it just didn't
have a promising by I don't have the
same vibe is the
it's the entertaining those kids dig it
they try men next current event please
sure
henry cavill oh yeah it says he won't
flirt with women anymore in case he's
called a rapist or something as he did a
interview a junkie a lot of she got
roasted so he had to do a like a rip
bottle of course I'm not a rebuttal but
uh he had to make a statement of what he
said yeah so you want to see the
original thing he says yes it's very
difficult to do that
it started with you saw my flirting with
women it's very difficult to do that if
there's certain rules in place because
then it's like well I don't want to go
up and talk to her because I'm gonna be
called a rapist or something so you're
like forget it
I'm gonna call an ex-girlfriend instead
and they just go back to Alicia but I
get it that he said he's look they did
it did lighting suggest that when you're
in the public eye when you're an actor
on set or whatever that we are all super
careful now
I mean I'm I can tell you on my TV show
I will be nothing but the most formal of
all time I think so because it's fun to
flirt it's fun to be silly but believe
me if I don't know that person and
they're on a set I promise you it's
going to be formal as [ __ ] frankly I've
always been that I've always been that
way since I did [ __ ] inside Schwartz
I have I've always been when I work I'm
always careful of that because I've I've
i had a talking to easy to talking to
when I was younger and of makeup bars
when I was on MADtv said listen to me
right now I got any show told me about
some people who got in trouble and I
went [ __ ] for that oh I scared ya but
this it's a little extreme though I mean
be called a rapist yeah I think he was
just he's probably pissed you know I
don't know I mean Henry Cavill is that
also a target he's a stud women love him
the sauces haven't seen the reaction
article in particular about my feelings
on dating in me to mood I just want to
apologize for any confusion
misunderstood and set see it was
absolutely not my intention and light of
others so just like to clarify oka D
hold women the highest regard right
never intended to just revoke their blah
blah blah sucky sucky suck
yeah I mean and it's also a bummer he
has to say that he presents that's also
bummer that he's been forced to say that
this is whatever this is what you don't
mean you know I mean so that now now now
you're forced into a formal apology that
you didn't even right now the even
bigger story do you have this where
Scarlett Johansson was suppose to play a
transgender have you seen this oh so she
this eh she got greenlit to play a
transgender woman a lead the transgender
community protest so bad all of them but
the majority of them protested so bad
she goes you know I don't want this
backlash I'm not doing the movie anymore
so you know what the studio did went
we're not doing the movie at all the
transgender community goes
we won yeah and everyone else go no you
did it because what was gonna happen is
this movie was gonna shed light correct
on well its life for life with you'll
arm and make people more a huge star and
make people more aware of what you guys
go through and I think you won because a
transgender person in play it you
[ __ ] morons and apparently now you
have to be the person to play it how
interesting
I know somebody who I've been working
with who's dealing with that too it's
like if you're not part of the if you're
not the exact Native American tribe
apparently you have to get permission
from the Native American tribe no I I
mean we're actors what do you have to
check my family treated plan Italian
well she well she goes she goes hold on
she owes
originally and I think it was a great
initial response Sheila's Jared Leto won
an Oscar for playing a transgender
person in Dallas buyers club
how many Germany Tim Bacchus was named
Tim Bacchus or tambul Tambora for
example or plays plays a transgender
Jared Leto wasn't really transiency
there the other actor who helps you you
[ __ ]
the actor that will just live why not
trans Jeff light on the situation for
drama and it's called get the best actor
just like you get the best comedian up
there you [ __ ] dummies it's called a
meritocracy who's the most competent and
then how about they go well you tell me
a transgender person can't play this
know who's the best transgender actor
maybe the director tried out transgender
was like oh sure not good no Scarlett
Jones who can actor
I can pull a small petal did plug that
better I'll do you one better
Brian could pull that I know I would are
you gonna pour gonna force are you gonna
force investors to put their money
behind a transgender person nobody knows
who can't put any butts in the seat no
it's the bottom line Joe Rogan makes
more money than I do as a comic dude
because he's funny
dude no that's not what I was gonna do
that a huge podcast that's better than
yours
no what is it more people like him me
because he's better that's not the part
come on let's read back oh no that's not
nevermind okay and I ruined it anyway
yeah it's called who's the best person
for the job you [ __ ] dummies but I
don't care keep it you guys lost you
[ __ ] you took a huge L on this you
took a huge [ __ ] Alice of course Oh
buck angel will use buck hmm we'll use
Chaz Bono yay cuz I put butts in the
seat yeah Oh Scarlett Johansson as
transgender Chaz Bono I'm trying to make
Bank bro whatever pisses me off
it's called equality of outcome not
equality of opportunity what else you
got Jim this is such an interesting
topic because the next current event
which wasn't planned but the the tie key
rescue is obviously about Thai people
right yeah so I guess this director his
name's Jon M Chu he's developing a film
about the Thai keep the Thai cave rescue
but he wants to make sure he does it so
that it doesn't get quote-unquote
whitewashed as in like with white actors
a different store like they'll follow
the same story but they make it
Hollywood with that it's this has been
so public Hollywood's not gonna there's
been a history of it so I understand
well what we'd what no no there hasn't
no well there's a history of us taking
you know Asian Japanese Chinese moves
then placing white actors in there like
the Great Wall with Matt Damon that's
different cuz that's all made up that's
not a real story it sure the last
samurai had Tom Cruise and
and also stop cruise and we all went to
see it yes it's Tom Cruise yes
Oh cause he's the biggest movie star in
the world so it was a phenomenal movie
once again white dude out of Syracuse
and sure Great Wall the Great Wall with
Matt Damon out that part's true that
one's tricky yeah however this of course
this guy's gonna do it you gotta put
tight people in it Holly was I can do
that they're gonna get that extreme what
if you have a Filipino guy in there and
he's a great actor can't have it and he
looks tough when you tie bro big no I
think I just don't want all white kids
does not why we're so scared right yeah
Bryan Callen is one of the Thai soccer
player they cast Brian Eno Brenda jobs
in the bet I got he's a giant white
Brian and Brendan as how much how that's
I'm starving Downey is funny
I'll send food now I should do we should
I have an idea for a sketch um who's
gonna play the take Elon Musk what else
get Jen just this last one here so
Nevada was supposed to use fentanyl for
an execution
mr. president due to a lot of its
expiring not fentanyl though so that
would be the first time they would have
used it but of course all these drug
companies including fentanyl's makers
they're like they had to stop it because
they don't want their drug obviously
terrible dude I don't know what he did
I'm saying
physically though dimepiece he looks
like yeah he looks like an actor what do
you do looks like Stevie Blue has it be
a growth spurt well it would he is a
double-murder I think there's a woman in
a little girl or something oh my god up
again so he's repeatly state he wants to
be executed yeah he wants to die an
excuse to use a three-drug cocktail has
been set for Wednesday evening in Nevada
experts say will be the first time the
opioid fentanyl was used a you execution
the pharmaceutical company filed a
lawsuit hey farmer let me just get it
done right now what else so what all did
he do keeps going down
many states all right keep going what
are seeing he added he doesn't say what
he's dead I'll keep going down there
goes
those are doze air was sent to the death
over the over the first degree murder in
Toronto of Jeremiah Miller who's just
dismembered body was found in a trash
bin in Las Vegas now those are known as
the volunteer or a death row inmate as a
banded future Appeals so he just killed
a dude and masters of this timepiece I
think she killed a woman yeah Jen this
trying to make him feel bad for him
hi miss remember dude-on-dude crime one
word over that 22 year old boy god yeah
what exactly do though
that's a scary-looking dude though he's
a big boy yeah keep going
let me see just go through that's a
weird head handsome guy though yeah he's
he's handsome but let me find out
exactly what he did oops dismembered a
man but what I need there logistics here
got cuz they it must've been really
baffling any of you [ __ ] murders on
April he met Dozier at a look contra a
motel in Las for a strip doozer I
promised to help Miller by a Federer in
a key ingredient in the prediction of
math Miller had brought 12 thousand cash
for the expense pon Noah's arrival does
their kill them likely by shooting salt
Noah's body into multiple pieces stuff
most of them in a suitcase and dispose
near apartment complex that's it it's
terrible it's a drug killer killing
another drug killer yeah drug dealer
drugged but I think there's something
about cutting the body up well know when
you're in the inverse of doing it to cry
a drug crime and you kill somebody
there's all these like things in
probably Nevada don't get me wrong it's
terrible but I figured their beans were
I know you mean there's much worse I
thought see me like he shot another man
he robbed and shot another man he's a
bad guy but yeah I know you mean like
they're there our way well yeah I
thought it well things to children oh
yeah
die child well if that kill him but do
tendu drug dealers burst drug dealer
crime kidnap a woman rape her and kill
her you should die you know but but this
is I know you mean there are there are
then is what we get back to degrees
there's levels to this game
raveh tea I mean bad dude nonetheless
good-looking man briefly served in the
military enough to put him into a woman
he had begun dating in high school had a
son by mid twenties he was making much
of his income from the rocks and sale of
meth businessman during the course of
which he was balance between Nevada and
Arizona the two states of which he was
convicted of murder
Tuesdays see that's farewell to States
comment what's his other the only one
they caught us him selling another dude
than cutting them up but clearly a bad
guy hiking him on the streets can we but
says victims are only no lifelong drug
dealer so you know I didn't want to get
caught none of you want your drug
dealers look about that 12 grand you
know anyway it's a tragedy for the
parents yeah either way deal I think
you're doing buying ephedrine though you
know I'm also you were involved in the
production math and doing yeah both bad
guys don't do that don't me another kid
deserves like sawing me it's like this
song the body losses if I say to you
Brendan if I go make a little extra cash
okay ask me how how okay so don't judge
me all I'm doing is there's a dude who
deals meth he's been doing it a long
time he's got great connection okay all
I'm doing is bringing some product to a
hotel room cuz he needs it to make his
meth okay so I'm just bringing some
ephedrine and he's gonna pay me in cash
okay pretty cool so yes I'm involved in
the in the manufacture of meth and I
don't know the guy but I do know that
he's big and that he's been doing it a
long time chances are you're probably
say hey Bry nope I would say can I give
you 10 grand so we can double our
products pect that real good you're kind
of cold should I come with and we have
him now you're speaking now you come
with and we're on take your stuff and
he's away it's not smart shoots his load
shoots us both oh hey man you're kind of
turned on by that guy no hurry up
Max's haven't chosen all right change
that late and gentle on thank you and
we'll see you in Chicago
we're so sound Chicago show so boom
seeing Chicago Thursday
Friday I'll be open up for Brian and
then I am in Austin first week of August
and then second week of August so I'm in
Dallas all those shows are almost sold
out I think four or five shows in each
city
damn it all of them sold out t fat cake
on four tickets and then my tickets for
Seattle just went on sale September
Seattle tik calm Wednesday Wednesday the
collab neverending summer class sure
crime kid one of our first shirts we've
ever done we bring them back out and
it's all new and remix I'm wearing it
right now as you guys listen to show the
roots of Fight Club you get on route to
fight dot-com get them while they're hot
they got tanks for the summer they get
the black tees they got it all get um
well get them
see you guys in Chicago this is a father
kid we're out